قبل ساعتين وبقرار سياسي غادر الرئيس
المعزول عمر البشير مع اربعه قيادات
الرفيعه مستشفى علياء التابع للمؤسسه
العسكريه بعد بقائهم فيه 10 اشهر حياته لم
تكن طبيعيه لكنها افضل حالا من السجن هنا
كانوا يزورون بعضهم ويمارسون قليلا من
الرياضه ويستقبلون الاهل والاصدقاء
المقربين في غرف ضيقه لكن خارج اسوار هذه
المستشفى كانت عضويه المؤتمر الوطني
المنحل تجتمع وطنشاط لك كيفيه العوده
للمشهد السياسي
رساله من القياده العسكريه الى المؤتمر
الوطني المنحل تقول اننا اعدنا سجنا
الرموز وقادرون على فعل المزيد وهو ما
تجاهلته هيئه الدفاع في ردها وتمسكت بعدم
قانونيه القرار
السلطه القضائيه وعدم احترام للقضاء ولا
لهيبته
وينبغي للهيئه القضائيه ان تسال ذلك
قيادتهم من الحزب المعزول التقط باعضاء من
الاليه الثلاثيه بحسب مصادر موثوقه
وابلغتهم انه في حال تم استثنائهم سيقومون
بما لا تحمد عقبه ومنها تحريك عناصرهم
لانفاذ انقلاب عسكري فجاء الرد الجيش
للمؤتمر الوطني المسلحه
قبل يومين تزامنا مع توتر متصاعد بين
انصار الحزب المعزول من الحركه الاسلاميه
الذين سيروا تظاهرات امام بعثه دبلوماسيه
والسلطه العسكريه
من علياء حسين
كانوا موجودين في عاليه
تصنيعا وليس مرض
السياسي بين تسويه مع الحريه والتغيير او
الابقاء على الوثيقه الدستوريه الحاليه
تفاعل الشارع مع هذه الخطوات
الصاحب افترض يحصل لكن
ده شغل سياسي واضح السجن او افضل من
المستشفى لانه ما مضمونه السودان بالاضاع
الحاليه هي ما خطوه بشري يعني لانه اصلا
يعني كلهم ما كانوا عيانين يعني المرض
اللي بخلي الزور يقعد في المستشفى ورابط
السنه
مجددا والذي لا يسمح الاقتراب منه فهل
ستدور معارك قانونيه وطبيه لاخراجهم ام
انه سيشهد مزيدا من الاعتقالات لقيادات
اخرى لين يعقوب العربيه الخرطوم